général mes chers collègues je vous
propose nous sommes parfaitement à
l'heure donc nous conservions cet
avantage et que nous démarrions donc
notre audition en général nous sommes
heureux de vous accueillir pour cette
audition sur la guerre en Ukraine et ses
enseignements nous avons récemment
auditionné le colonel Michel Goya à ce
sujet et après avoir entendu un terrien
si je puis dire nous nous réjouissons de
pouvoir bénéficier ce matin du regard
d'un navigateur sur cette guerre votre
éclairage vous sera en effet précieux
vous avez effectué 35 années de service
dans l'armée de l'air de 1978 à 2013
comme pilote de chasse puis en état
majeur et à plusieurs postes à
responsabilité au sein du secrétariat
général de la Défense nationale du
commandement du soutien des forces
aériennes et enfin comme directeur de la
sécurité aéronautique de l'État vous
avez donc aussi une grande expérience du
regard intéraarmé ce qui nous sera
précieux puis de 2014 à 2021 vous avez
exercé les fonctions de conseiller du
président Dassault Aviation avant de
créer votre propre société de conseils
en stratégie notre commission est très
attentive à ce que la France ne passe
pas à côté des enseignements de la
guerre en Ukraine certes ce conflit est
loin d'être achevé ce qui nous oblige à
une certaine prudence peut-être pourrait
vous d'ailleurs nous livrer votre
analyse de la situation sur le terrain
alors que les villes et infrastructures
ukrainiennes continuent d'être bombardé
par les Russes faute pour eux de pouvoir
repousser la contre-offensive
ukrainienne à l'est et au sud comment le
rapport de force est-il susceptible
d'évoluer au cours d'une guerre qui
s'annonce malheureusement longue
cette guerre n’épuise pas bien sûr elle
seule l'ensemble des problématiques de
la réflexion prospective mais toutes les
caractéristiques de ce conflit de haute
intensité sur le sol européen devront
être prises en compte dans la prochaine
loi de programmation militaire
actuellement en préparation par le
gouvernement c'est pourquoi la
Commission a constitué un groupe de
travail sur le retour d'expérience du
conflit
ukrainien
dont les rapporteurs sont nos collègues
Cédric Perrin et Jean-Marc deschini il
s'agit d'évaluer quelle est la portée de
cette guerre sur le plan géostratégique
et quels sont ses enseignements sur le
plan militaire vous livrerez bien sûr en
particulier votre analyse de l'usage de
l'arme aérienne dans ce conflit les
Russes n'ont pas acquis la supériorité
aérienne semble-t-il ce qui a été pour
beaucoup une surprise l'ont-ils cherché
et sinon pourquoi dans la doctrine
occidentale l'acquisition de la priorité
aérienne reste essentielle nous avons vu
une nouvelle fois après la guerre au
Karaba l'usage massive des drones ce
changement fondamental repose sur
l'usage de drones relativement peu
coûteux mais aux effets pardon
cinétiques et psychologique dévastateur
quelle sera la place de l'aviation de
combat dans ce nouveau contexte le
concept du fait-il selon vous adapté à
ses évolutions nous sommes aussi
préoccupés par le retard de la France en
matière de drones mais aussi par la
rareté de notre défense solaire et de
nos capacités de suppression des
défenses aériennes adverses nous
disposons de moyens de haute technologie
enviées de tous en particulier des
Ukrainiens mais dans des quantités quasi
échantillonnaires ou fixer le partage
entre le contenu technologique et la
masse c'est une question que nous nous
posons aussi en général je vous propose
d'aborder ces questions dans un propos
liminaire de 15 à 20 minutes et après
quoi je donnerai la parole à mes
collègues pour un échange de
questions-réponses et je vous rappelle
que cette audition est captée et
diffusée sur le site internet du Sénat
en général vous avez la parole
merci beaucoup monsieur le
vice-président Monsieur et Madame les
sénateurs merci beaucoup de m'accueillir
ici pour parler de la guerre en Ukraine
alors que ce que vous n'avez pas dit
c'est que en plus de tout ce que vous
avez dit je suis également commentateur
de la guerre en Ukraine sur une chaîne
de télévision depuis 8 mois qui m'occupe
souvent tous les matins de 6 heures à 9h
avec un agrise particulière c'est de
traiter en une minute un sujet très
compliqué bon donc je vais essayer
d'être synthétique mais je vais faire un
peu plus de 15 minutes si vous terminez
nous comptons sur votre concision mais
vous avez plus de 15 minutes souhaitez
donc
je vais essayer d'être clair s'agissant
d'un sujet qui est évidemment important
pour notre sécurité je vais faire plutôt
une analyse stratégique que tactique
parce que les aviateurs ont l'habitude
de prendre un petit peu de hauteur et ça
aide pour voir d'en haut le déroulé de
ce conflit alors d'abord un point
important après en bulle si vous voulez
bien depuis le début de mes commentaires
ou de mes analyses je m'attache à
l'analyse des faits j'évite la morale ou
l'émotion
alors première partie
on va mettre pardon on va
tenter de faire fonctionner la
technologie et je dois viser quelque
part je pense
je vous laisse appuyer sur la flèche si
vous voulez bien voilà ça c'est le plan
comprendre éclairer les fonctions
présents la guerre les acteurs
extérieures vous avez les différents
points que je vais abordés dans la
première partie et puis dans la deuxième
les forces en présence d'abord il faut
bien comprendre que les deux armées
ukrainien et russes sont sortis des
mêmes moules le moule de l'Union
soviétique elle mettait en œuvre au
début de la guerre les mêmes équipements
militaires les mêmes chars les mêmes
défenses solaires les mêmes chasseurs la
même artillerie deux armées qui ont
conservé longtemps les modes de
fonctionnement rigides et centralisé des
forces soviétiques
la seule différence environ 10 fois plus
de tous ces équipements du côté russe
souvent un standard plus avancé et
aucune marine de guerre du côté
ukrainien depuis 2014 un rapport de
puissance évidemment en faveur des
Russes qui auraient dû faire la
différence cela n'a pas été le cas on va
essayer de comprendre pourquoi du côté
ukrainien à l'invasion russe en Crimée
et le début de la guerre dans le bon
basse en 2014 vont servir d'électrochoc
la guerre n'a pas commencé en 2022 elle
a commencé en 2014 à partir de 2014
l'OTAN d'un côté les États-Unis le
Canada et la Grande-Bretagne de l'autre
vont commencer à former l'armée
ukrainienne et au début de la guerre on
estime que 40000 des 80000 soldats de
l'armée régulière ont été formés par les
Occidentaux et combattent donc à
l'occidental je vais souvent utiliser ce
terme combattre l'occidental par rapport
à combattre à la soviétique qui est le
cas des Russes il y a même eu la
création d'unités de force spéciale qui
vont se montrer extrêmement efficace sur
le théâtre d'opération quant aux forces
Russell elles elles n'ont rien à voir
avec les forces soviétiques en
particulier en ce qui concerne la
quantité en réalité elles sont très
réduites parce que si Poutine a préservé
et même moderniser ses forces nucléaires
la modernisation de ces forces
conventionnelles va être très loin
d'être achevée au moment où se déclenche
l'offensive ainsi les super charmata ou
les super chasseurs succoï 57 ne sont
pas du tout engagés dans cette opération
la réalité c'est que les forces
nucléaires en Russie captent une large
part des crédits au détriment des
capacités conventionnelles russes
l'armée russe est minée par la
corruption et par la violence à l'image
de la société russe pas la médiocrité de
chef militaire et par le manque
d'entraînement parachutiste appelé
fraîchement engagé professionnel
mercenaire de Wagner soldats de cadirov
ce n'est pas une armée si la
juxtaposition d'armée différente sur le
champ de bataille agissant des façons
non coordonnées et surtout elles sont
trop réduites en nombre il faut pas
oublier que la Fédération de Russie
c'est 17 millions de kilomètres carrés
soit 30 fois la taille de la France et
elle comporte 85 sujets pour un budget
de la défense de l'ordre d'une fois et
de mieux celui de la France
le rapport des forces le rapport de
force va être progressivement modifié
avec les livraisons massives
d'équipements militaires à l'Ukraine
d'abord les équipements ex soviétiques
de la part des anciens pays du parc des
Varsovie puis très rapidement des
équipements occidentaux avec une
importante limite ou l'ignorance sur
laquelle je reviendrai pour résumer la
situation du début de la guerre et c'est
toujours celle d'aujourd'hui les
Ukrainiens ont des combattants
involonter mais pas assez d'armement les
Russes sont de l'armement à volonté mais
pas assez de combattants
deuxième partie la guerre la guerre est
une somme des batailles de phases elle
n'est pas linéaire celle-ci peut se
décomposer en quatre phases l'invasion
ratée la nouvelle stratégie russe la
contre-offensive ukrainienne ukrainienne
pardon l'hiver et la campagne aérienne
la première phase c'est celle de
l'invasion manquée elle débute le 24
février et va durer 45 jours jusqu'à la
mi-avril le temps que Poutine réalise
que ces généraux lui mentent une
offensive russe repoussée par les
Ukrainiens qui s'est terminé par un
désastre stratégique et militaire pour
la Russie les explications de ce
désastre sont multiples mais c'est
d'abord la conséquence d'une analyse
totalement
erronée des Russes sur trois points la
première c'est l'existence d'une nation
ukrainienne le deuxième c'est la
surestimation de la puissance de l'armée
russe et le troisième c'est la
sous-estimation de la puissance de
l'armée ukrainienne les Russes pensaient
que la résidence ienne serait minime et
que Kiev est le dombage tomberait aussi
facilement que la Crimée en 2014 une
faute majeure de la part de Poutine et
de ses services de renseignement dont
d'ailleurs il mangera très rapidement la
plupart des chefs ce qu'il continue à
faire régulièrement
vis-à-vis de ces généraux par exemple
c'est ainsi que la fine fleur de l'armée
russe qui sont les forces parachutistes
qui sont totalement indépendantes et
super équipées et bien se sont fait
décimer lorsqu'elles ont tenté fait une
tentative de débarquement aéroportée sur
les semaines lors de la prise de Kiev
tout au début de la guerre
dans cette phase les Russes vont
conquérir tout de même sans pratiquement
aucun combat une grande partie du
territoire de l'Ukraine dont la ville et
la région de Kerson et la centrale
nucléaire de saporub Jack défaille de la
conique depuis le début de la guerre
cette face cette deuxième phase se
termine le 18 avril avec une humiliation
majeure pour Russie pour la Russie la
marine ukrainienne qui n'a pas de bateau
zéro bateau ils avaient une frégate
qu'ils ont saborder le 3 mars elle
arrive à couler le plus puissant navire
de la flotte le croiseur moxva le plus
puissant bateau le bateau amiral de la
faute de la flotte noire de la flotte
russe en mer Noire pendant une
humiliation majeure pour les Russes
qu'ils essaieront de cacher le plus
longtemps possible les Ukrainiens ont
gagné la première phase de la guerre
sans aucune ambiguïté commencez alors la
deuxième phase c'est celle de la
nouvelle stratégie russe il s'agit de
concentrer pour la Russie les efforts
sur le don-basse d'abord et sur le
contrôle de la mer Noire ensuite cette
phase va durer quatre mois jusqu'au mois
d'août les Russes vont progresser dans
le don-basse au prix de lourdes pertes à
la mi-juillet ils vont avoir pris le
contrôle de la totalité de l'aublage de
Lougansk et 80% de celui de Donetsk les
Russes contrôlent à présent une partie
importante de l'Ukraine plus les 27000
km² de la Crimée mais ils sont toujours
confrontés au même problème pas assez
d'hommes toujours pas assez d'hommes et
un commandement défaillant ils vont
néanmoins gagner cette deuxième phase de
la guerre avec deux victoires
symboliques la conquête de la totalité
de l'aublasque de l'audience que je le
dis et surtout la victoire la prise de
la ville martyre de Mario Paul dont tout
le monde a suivi les différents épisodes
par contre ils vont se montrer incapable
de poster l'offensive jusqu'à au dessin
c'est un point important au dessin ne
tombera pas donc évidemment Poutine va
être obligé de revoir ses objectifs à la
baisse d'ailleurs dans cette guerre et
deux chefs de guerre que sont-elles
inscrit et Poutine passe leur temps à
revoir leurs objectifs de guerre ça je
pense que c'est un élément important
pour comprendre des décrypter cette
guerre pour la Russie c'est toujours le
même problème pas assez d'hommes pour un
front des 1000 km du côté ukrainien la
mobilisation est décidée le premier jour
elle porte ses fruits des dizaines de
milliers de combattants armés par les
Occidentaux ont renforcé les rangs de
l'armée régulière la nation ukrainienne
est en arme elle est galvanisée par un
chef exceptionnel veut devenir élanski
la troisième phase est celle de la
contre-offensive ukrainienne cette phase
de sera visible qu'au mois d'août avec
les mouvements de troupe mais en réalité
elle a commencé dès le mois de juin
grâce à la livraison de canons comme le
canon César mais surtout grâce au High
mars
américain britannique et allemand ce
sont des armes qui frappent loin et fort
avec une très grande précision grâce au
guidage satellite des obus et au
renseignement US bien évidemment chaque
requête tirée est un coût au but pendant
des semaines les Ukrainiens vont
s'empolier à détruire le deuxième
échelon russe c'est-à-dire la logistique
des peaux de carburant les dépôts de
munitions en outre les Ukrainiens vont
concevoir une opération de déception
remarquable ils vont faire croire au
Russe qu'ils vont attaquer la Carson au
sud alors qu'il lance la contrefensive
au nord de la région de kerkiv n'ayant
pas assez d'hommes les Russes n'ont pas
d'autres solutions que le sous-couper
soit la main droite ou la main gauche et
choisiront de sauver Kerson et cela va
entraîner une débâcle dans le Nord le 21
septembre Poutine déclare la
mobilisation partielle et Alex les
territoires occupés un nouveau tournant
dans cette guerre la troisième phase la
phase de la contrepensive et gagner par
les Ukrainiens nous sommes actuellement
dans la quatrième phase la quatrième
phase a commencé le 8 octobre alors vous
souvenez le 8 octobre c'est une date
importante c'est la de l'attentat contre
le pont de kirsch qui relie la Crimée à
la Russie attentat qui n'a toujours pas
été revendiqué par définition puisqu'il
est clandestins donc la définition de la
collagilité c'est qu'on sait pas qui
c'est bon on a quand même une petite
idée
une humiliation pour Poutine cette
affaire du pont de kerche qui va
d'ailleurs en profiter pour nommer je
pense qu'il avait il avait déjà calcu
avant un nouveau général à la tête des
opérations il s'appelle sorovikin et sur
revikine n'est pas un aviateur mais il a
commandé les forces russes en Syrie dans
lequel il largement utilisé la version
bombardement et surtout il a également
commandé les forces aérospatiale russe
et les forces aérospatiales russes c'est
aussi l'armée Dar russe donc pour la
première fois on a un général terrien à
la tête de l'opération qui connaît
l'aviation et la puissance aérienne à
partir de sa nomination la guerre va
changer de nature
cette phase comporte également le
retrait finalement inattendu des troupes
russes de Kerson qui se replient pour la
première fois en bonne ordre et qui va
ainsi vont éviter un encerclement et une
défaite probablement inévitable et c'est
à ce moment-là que sur Viking va décider
de lancer la première campagne aérienne
rue russe vraiment efficace des raids
incessantes de drone iraniens shell 136
vous on les voit bien c'est drone je
pourrais en parler mais surtout des
raids des bombes à des stratégiques qui
décollent de base russe située à moins
de 40 minutes de vol de la frontière
tout à l'heure je vous montrais une
photo de Tupolev 160 un tupolève 160 ça
peut emporter et tirer 12000 sites de
croisière qui font 2500 km de portée et
qui ont une charge militaire de 400 kg
c'est bombardiers ne franchissent même
pas la frontière ils sont donc
totalement invulnérables
la seule solution pour les Ukrainiens
est alors d'intercepter ses missiles ce
qui est possible mais évidemment il
manque de système de défense anti-aérien
c'est ce qui m'ont réclamer à partir de
à partir de cette date là les cibles
sont d'abord des cibles
d'infrastructures civiles mais aussi des
cibles plus militaires comme les usines
d'armement et les sites militaires
je précise parce que je l'ai rajouté
entre-temps donc j'ai parlé de les
Russes les Ukrainiens depuis dimanche et
c'est un événement important de cette
guerre ont décidé de frapper ces bases
aériennes avec des drones de
renseignements de la guerre froide
bricoler qui sont transformés en missile
de croisière et ça c'est un nouveau
tournant dans la guerre et on en parlera
peut-être un peu plus tard
l'objectif de la campagne aérienne il
est double premièrement c'est faire
souffrir la population alors que l'hiver
arrive mais aussi paralyser l'économie
ukrainienne afin de freiner l'effort de
guerre
dans le même temps les Russes prennent
des positions défensives pour protéger
la Crimée cela arrive gauche du Nièvre
le Nièvre puissant et large qui
constitue une ligne naturelle de
séparation difficilement franchissable
c'est là où nous en sommes aujourd'hui
c'est la petite Raspoutine ça la petite
période des pluies qui va précéder les
chutes de neige et l'arrivée et
l'arrivée des sols gelés la question et
est-ce que c'est cette météo va
permettre aux Ukrainiens de reprendre
l'offensive ou aux Russes de reprendre
du terrain sur les Ukrainiens la nous
allons le savoir bientôt par contre ce
qu'on sait c'est que la campagne
aérienne va se poursuivre aussi
longtemps que la Russie aura des
missiles pour le moment malgré les
prévisions cela ne semble pas poser de
problème je rappelle que l'été dernier
Poutine a fait voter un occase qui fait
passer l'économie russe en économie de
guerre c'est la priorité aux usines
d'armement en Russie en ce moment
on va parler à présent
des des questions concernant le rôle des
acteurs extérieurs
il est évident que sans la formation de
l'armée de l'armée ukrainienne débutée
en 2014 et sans les livraisons massives
des armes fournies aux Ukrainiens le
sort de cette guerre aurait été
différente malgré la Bravo les soldats
Ukrainiens 50 pays participent au groupe
de Ramstein qui c'est un groupe qui sous
l'autorité américaine Cordonne les
livraison de tous types d'armements
fournis par les Occidentaux qui ne sont
pas occidentaux il y a deux japonais des
Israéliens des Coréens du Sud je les
appellerai
occidentaux si vous voulez bien les
Etats-Unis ont même créé un état majeur
à cette pour coordonner cet effort en
Allemagne donc c'est un effort colossal
qui aujourd'hui se montre à plus de 20
milliards d'armement livrés en tout cas
en théorie ce qui représente quatre fois
le budget de la défense ukrainienne la
nature des armes a bien sûr évolué en
fonction des quatre phases de la guerre
la coordination entre l'OTAN et les
forces ukrainiennes est très étroites et
permanente
certains pays considèrent que la Russie
va passer son offensive au-delà de
l'Ukraine il livre ainsi massivement
leurs armements au risque de s'affaiblir
c'est le cas de la Pologne et les pays
baltes pour des raisons historiques
facilement compréhensible on peut dire
que ces pays font vraiment une guerre
par procuration contre la Russie ce
n'est pas le cas de tout de tous les
pays au-delà des armements et de la
formation associée les Occidentaux
américains en tête fournissent leurs
renseignement militaire permanent et
extrêmement précis et totalement décisif
dans cette guerre
ainsi il permet aux Ukrainiens de
connaître la position de chaque canon de
chaque char de chaque unité russe qui
fait que la manœuvre militaire en est
facilités du côté ukrainien du côté
russe on ne connaît pas le niveau du
renseignement mais il doit être quand
même de bonne qualité ils ont un grand
nombre de satellites d'observation
la livraison de 25000 terminaux Starling
par Elon Musk au début de la guerre
garantit une circulation de la formation
pour les responsables politiques et au
sein des unités militaires enfin le
Pentagone ne cache pas de fournir un
conseil opérationnel comme par exemple
lors de la contre-offensive des
Ukrainiens qui a été planifié au
Pentagone par les américains avec les
Ukrainiens
en ce qui concerne la France nous ne
donnons que ce que nous pouvons donner
parce que nous n'avons pas grand chose à
donner en réalité mais à la différence
de certains le ministre le rappelle nous
donnons tout ce que nous avons tout ce
que nous allonsçons et c'est pas le cas
des autres enfin le soutien militaire de
l'Iran qui est apparu au mois de juin en
matière de drone est évidemment un
facteur important la question a priori
de savoir si ce soutient va se
poursuivre et se diversifier aussi les
Iraniens vont s'arrêter là quant à la
Chine une question à laquelle une
question une participation qui interroge
tout le monde elle ne fournit rien à
priori il est évident qu'elle a trop
peur des sanctions que les Américains
ont brandit alors cette image montre
quelques-uns des systèmes qui ont qui
font la différence il y a des systèmes
assez classiques et les choses très
exotiques comme par exemple vous voyez
la photo du milieu c'est le premier
c'est les Ukrainiens ont mené
l'offensive contre la marine
russe en mer Noire et dans le port de
Sébastopol avec des drones navales qui
sont fabriqués eux-mêmes qui sont des
qui sont pas rudimentaires qui ont des
capacités militaires qui leur permettent
de l'utiliser pour la première fois
c'est la première fois que dans une
opération un pays utilise et dédron
aérien et des drones navales pour nous
baigner une opération contre contre la
marine russe on voit l'échelle 136 en
bas à droite là qui sont redoutables du
coup ça coûte 20000 euros pièce c'est
une charge militaire de 45 kg et ça peut
faire 1500 km c'est facile à intercepter
mais quand vous en lancer une salle de
50 il y en a au moins 30 qui passe les
fameux imars le Switchblade les
munitions rodeuses qui sont redoutables
à munition rodeuse et ça se met dans le
sac à dos d'infantassin ça se tire avec
un mortier comme un mortier un petit
tube la munition déploie ses ailes elle
prend son envol elle monte en altitude
le soldat prend une petite commande et
voilà la télécommander au dessus d'une
cible qui peut être un char qui peut
être une position d'infanterie et il
attendra que la cible soit détectée pour
envoyer sa munition pour l'instant c'est
Manuel mais il y a des versions
automatiques qui arrivent sur le marché
bon la guerre c'est formidable pour
avancer les armes ça sert à ça donc il
faut quand même qu'on oublie pas quelque
chose moi j'étais surpris par l'émotion
sur les plateaux de télévision les
journalistes découvraient que la mer la
guerre ça faisait des morts le but de la
guerre c'est de faire des morts voilà et
le but des punitions c'est de faire des
morts alors on parlera après de des
conventions internationales des règles
de la guerre bien sûr que il faut
humaniser organiser la guerre mais cela
qu'on assiste c'est une guerre à
laquelle on n'avait pas assisté depuis
longtemps je reviendrai peut-être sur
certains de ces sujets pendant les
questions et je ressortirai cette image
par rapport aux besoins de nos armées
dans la dans la prochaine loi de
programmation militaire
rapidement les différents types de
guerre terrestres aérienne naval
cyberger dans l'espace et de la femme
vous savez qu'aujourd'hui les militaires
ne parle plus de guerre interarmée
terre-hermer il parle de milieux
militaire milieu marine milieu r milieu
espace milieu cyber et le milieu
informationnel on va regarder la façon
dont ces milieux ont été traités pendant
cette guerre d'abord la guerre de
l'information il est évident que
l'Ukraine a pris l'avantage dès le début
une propagande face et le propagande
russe très stéréotypée qui faisait
d'abord la population russe par contre
les Ukrainiens visent d'abord la
communauté internationale les Ukrainiens
ils nous parlent dans leur communication
alors que Poutine il parle la propagande
russe parle on n'est pas du tout sur le
même portage en réalité on sait pas
grand chose de fiable dans cette guerre
on peut même dire que si un domaine
mérite bien le mot de brouillard de
brouillard de la guerre c'est le
brouillard de la guerre de l'information
on n'a pas d'éléments fiables on n'a pas
d'éléments fiables sur le matériel
détruit on n'a pas le démangeable sur le
nombre de victimes le seul élément qu'on
a finalement objectif c'est celui qui a
été donné par le général Miley j'ai une
planche un peu plus loin le le chef
d'état-major des armées américaines il
l'a dit c'était il y a peut-être trois
semaines qu'il y a 100 000
soldats hors de combat hors de combat
donc blessé gravement puis reprendre pas
le combat mort et blessé gravement à la
fois du côté russe et du côté ukrainien
et 40 000 civils tués j'insiste sur le
nombre de 40 000 situations parce que
quand on est contre les comptes rendus
des tirs de missiles chaque fois il y en
a un ou deux hein non il y a pas un ou
deux il y a probablement 40 000 civils
tués dans cette guerre
deuxième élément la cyberguerre ça c'est
un domaine très confidentiel que les
nations ne partagent pas il faut naître
conscient donc on ne sait pas ce qui se
passe dans la cyberger par contre ce
qu'on sait c'est qu'on n'a pas assisté
au Grand Soir de l'acide bergère auquel
on aurait pu s'attendre bon ça c'est le
seul constat et évidemment tout ça ça se
déroule sous les radars les nations ne
partagent pas je pense que c'est
intéressant d'interroger le comme cyber
le responsable de la guerre cyber en
France pour dire donner sa vie sur ce
qui se passe en tout cas une chose est
certaine c'est que dans ce cadre ce
n'est pas une guerre du XXIe siècle et
la guerre du XXe siècle aura une
dimension cyber très importante c'est la
même chose pour la guerre dans l'espace
il n'y a pas de guerre dans l'espace
parce qu'en réalité les moyens sont
russes et américains et les Russes idées
américains font tout pour pas se
confronter directement donc c'est une
guerre du 20e siècle et pas une guerre
du 21e siècle de ce point de vue aussi
la guerre navale est elle aussi
particulière dans la mesure où les
Ukrainiens n'ont pas de marine comme je
l'ai dit pourtant ils ont réussi avec
leurs batteries côtières anti navire a
coulé le croiseur bosva et empêcher une
opération de débarquement amp à
direction de dessin et également à tenir
la frégate lance missile russe à
distance et la Turquie la spécialiste du
rôle trouble a joué un rôle important en
bloquant l'accès à la mer noire comme la
convention de notre lieu de tourisme un
petit peu d'aviation à présent le
principal échec de l'armée russe
concerne l'emploi ou plutôt le mauvais
emploi qu'elle a fait de sa puissante
aviation aérienne environ 500 chasseurs
une centaine de chasseurs bombardiers et
ceci dès les premières semaines de la
guerre les Russes sont montrés
incapables de conduire de campagne
aérienne comme l'OTAN l'aurait fait sous
leadership américain pour ce type
d'opération celle-ci aurait consisté à
détruire l'essentiel des radars des
systèmes de défense aériennes ainsi que
l'aviation ukrainienne afin d'obtenir la
supériorité aérienne condition
indispensable à la liberté d'action des
forces terrestres puis ensuite affaiblir
le potentiel militaire par des aériennes
et seulement ensuite ils auraient lancé
l'opération terrestre d'ailleurs c'est
bien ce que Zelinski avait compris et
c'est bien s'il craignait lorsque dès
les débuts de la guerre il a demandé à
l'OTAN une offre ryzen il s'attendait à
une campagne de supériorité aérienne
plus contre laquelle ces forces ne le
permettaient pas de résister
les Ukrainiens quant à eux ont été très
malins ils ont su protéger leur
cinquantaine de chasseurs ont un
déplaçants sur différentes bases et puis
ils sont situés à l'ouest et
heureusement la l'Ukraine est un grand
pays et puis ils ont surtout très bien
utilisé leur système mobile de défense
antiérienne de manière à neutraliser la
vie en russe on peut dire que c'était un
magnifique succès de l'armée de guerre
ukrainienne et à partir du moment où la
grande quantité de manpad vous savez ces
missiles qui sont tirés par l'épaule
sont arrivés à ce moment-là les Russes
ont plus n'ont plus pu utiliser
utilement leur aviation pour résumer les
Russes n'ont pas su utiliser leur
évaluation de chasse leur principal
échec de cette guerre jusqu'à l'arrivée
de sorovikin et j'en parle tout à
l'heure reste donc l'opération terrestre
elle est devenue le cœur de cette guerre
avec la guerre de mouvement et de
guérilla de la première phase elle est
devenue une guerre de destruction une
guerre de position et d'attrition par
artillerie aviation drone munition Rodez
lance-roquette multiple une guerre de
conquête des villages d'attaque et de
contre-attaques en quelque sorte une
guerre qui ressemble plus à la première
et la deuxième guerre mondiale une
guerre du 21e siècle et là à nouveau à
la puissance destructrice et au manque
de troupes des Russes les Ukrainiens ont
répondu par une maîtrise de la guerre et
de la manoeuvre terrestre très
supérieure à celle des Russes avec en
plus une force morale et une motivation
qui font des Borus qui font pas donc
défaut russe depuis le début
dans celle-ci je suis pas sûr que c'est
au bon endroit bon c'est pas grave voilà
des images de cette guerre les 100 000
soldats russes et ukrainiens hors de
combat les 40 000 annoncés par le
journal Miley le 10 novembre 2022
des images qui ont les mettre en noir et
blanc on est revenu en 1917 ou en 1940
on va parler de la question nucléaire
c'est mon sixième point et dernier point
de cette partie
je l'ai baptisé l'épée de Damoclès
nucléaire la question nucléaire
militaire et civile constituent une épée
de Damoclès depuis le début de cette
guerre le risque d'accident nucléaire
c'est cristallisé sur la centrale
accident nucléaire sur la centrale de
zapporuja très vite tombée entre les
mains des Russes je crois que c'est le 3
mars le président Macron a rappelé dans
son interview qu'il a donné depuis les
États-Unis l'importance de la sécurité
de cette centrale nucléaire située
malheureusement sur la ligne de front le
risque d'accident nucléaire reste majeur
il faut naître absolument conscient mais
cette guerre a surtout rappelé
l'importance de la dissuasion nucléaire
et de la grammaire nucléaire de la
dissuasion que nous nous sommes tous
ensemble mis à réapprendre
une situation inconnue depuis la fin de
l'URSS une gesticulation nucléaire faite
de menaces récurrentes que le président
Biden a comparé à l'affaire de la baie
des cochons en 1961 en allant jusqu'à
utiliser le mot Armageddon
c'est un conflit qui implique
directement la première puissance
nucléaire mondiale la Russie et
indirectement trois puissances
occidentales les États-Unis la France et
le Royaume-Uni mais aussi l'OTAN au
travers de sa dissuasion partagée je
parle des pays de l'OTAN qui mettent en
œuvre la bombe B61 américaine n'oublions
pas que si la Suède est la Finlande ont
tourné la page d'une très longue
neutralité c'est d'abord pour se mettre
sous la protection du parapluie
nucléaire américain
on n'a jamais parlé autant d'armes
nucléaires même à l'époque de la guerre
froide certains pardons ont annoncé une
guerre nucléaire dès les premiers jours
pas moi la menace nucléaire fait partie
de la grammaire nucléaire j'y reviendrai
lors des questions si vous le souhaitez
la principale chose qu'il faut retenir
c'est que la dissuasion nucléaire a
fonctionné pour les Français et pour le
temps la distillation nucléaire
française est remarquable dans son
concept et dans ses moyens les Français
ont appris à la connaître mais comme en
Russie elle était maintenue au détriment
de nos forces conventionnelles de haute
intensité c'est la première leçon
militaire de ce conflit pour la France
nous sommes le 7 décembre 2022 et
Poutine n'a toujours pas franchi le
Rubicon nucléaire cela conclut là vous
avez une image donc ça vous avez le
régiment de Bombardier russe avec des
des tubes 95 et tubes 160 qui opèrent à
partir de la base dangels qui est le
point rouge sur la carte en haut à
gauche
et bien cette base est à 40 minutes de
vol de la frontière ukrainienne les des
écoles ils tirent leur 10 8 ou 12
missiles sans passer la frontière il
rentre il recharge et il recommence donc
ça ne s'arrêtera que lorsque les Russes
n'ont plus de missiles on constate
qu'ils ont toujours des missiles comment
il fabrique je sais pas d'où ils
viennent je sais pas mais ils ont
toujours des missiles à tirer on a au
centre le général sur Viking le nouveau
patron des opérations militaires
pardon
à gauche vous avez un
160 et en haut à droite tu peux lève 95
avec les non autant Bert l'ours pour le
95 et baccalac pour les 160 c'est les
deux qui font le plus dégâts
actuellement sur l'Ukraine et les
missiles que j'ai nommés sont les
missiles qui font le plus de dégâts même
s'ils tirent beaucoup de missiles
différentes alors il se trouve que vous
avez une petite image une petite image
avec un drapeau ukrainien en haut à
gauche c'est le un drone chipolaire 141
qui a frappé la base d'Engel sans rouge
celle de ces bombardier en détruisant un
des bombardiers tu prélèves 195 ce sont
quoi ce sont des vieux drones de
renseignements de l'armée soviétique des
années 70 que les Ukrainiens ont bricolé
pourront faire des missiles de croisière
très précis puisqu'ils en tiré deux il y
a deux jours et un il y a trois jours
sur trois bases différentes donc je
reviendrai sur la question de peut-on
gagner une guerre du côté ukrainien si
on n'a pas le droit d'attaquer ou si on
ne peut pas attaquer son adversaire en
Russie la question est non donc on va
voir dans quelle mesure
assez frappent limité parce qu'ils n'ont
pas beaucoup de matériel pour le faire
peuvent changer le cours de la guerre
je termine si vous voulez bien les pets
de la molles
c'est un plan désordre mais mes images
mais vous voyez les principales en haut
à gauche c'est le missile s'attendait il
faut pas il faut pas oublier que pendant
les pendant les guerres les exercices
nucléaires continuent la validation des
nouveaux systèmes continuent en France
on continue à faire des exercices on
continue à développer
il a été tiré deux fois pendant cette
guerre c'est parce que les russes
continuent à le mettre au point alors
c'est impressionnant c'est un lien avec
la guerre ça cherche à marquer les
esprits mais ça fait partie du
développement normal des de la décision
de Leclerc dans tous les pays
mais effectivement on se rend compte que
que la dimension qu'a pris la dimension
nucléaire civile et militaire prise en
cette guerre est vraiment la principale
nouveauté et la façon dont la gérer est
quand même très compliqué pour les
occidentaux parce que la menace est
évidemment réelle
je termine donc maintenant par quelques
enseignements mais je valais très vite
parce que c'est plutôt pour alimenter la
discussion j'ai trois images
on va les lire ensemble on voyait bien
que quand la politique la diplomatie
échoue c'est la guerre on peut se poser
la question des accords de Minsk mais ce
qu'ils étaient sérieux est-ce qu'ils
auraient pu mettre mis en œuvre c'est
une bonne question s'il y a des avoir
des accords derrière quels sont les
accords solides suffisamment solides
pour que les deux parties en particulier
l'Ukraine il y a pas le sentiment qui
est plus cette réattaquée par la Russie
dans 5 ans c'est la première guerre aux
frontières de l'Europe c'est évident et
c'est une guerre très proche de la
guerre de 1945 c'est pour ça qu'on est
qu'on est traumatisé on a l'impression
de vivre ce que l'Europe a déjà vécu une
guerre asymétrique pour la Russie ce
n'est pas une guerre totale une guerre
totale c'est Barbarossa Barbarossa la
plus grande bataille de la deuxième
guerre mondiale entre les Allemands et
les Soviétiques 5 millions de morts du
côté des Soviétiques un million de morts
du côté des Allemands en 5 mois c'est
pas ça la guerre totale c'est qu'en deux
pays veulent se détruire là c'est un
pays qui veut prendre le contrôle d'un
autre pays donc c'est une guerre de
haute intensité mais il y a pire que ça
il y a une guerre de haute très haute
intensité qui est la guerre de survie
entre deux pays qui veulent survivre à
l'agression d'un autre pays ça ce point
est important une guerre par procuration
entre la Russie et l'Otan ça dépend des
pays je pense que la Pologne et les
Pays-Bas donnent tout leur armement aux
Ukrainiens parce que savent que si c'est
pas les inconvénients qui gagnent la
guerre ils auront à faire la guerre plus
tard contre la Russie je pense que c'est
pas le cas mais c'est une appréciation
personnelle c'est pas le cas de la
France la France est vraiment dans la
logique de d'aider l'Ukraine à se
défendre et pas des délukraine à
contre-attaquer je viendrai c'est un
point important dans la livraison des
armes mais on peut comprendre que pour
la Pologne et les pays baltes ils ont
pas les mêmes inquiétudes que nous et
ils ont eu raison d'ailleurs dans la
façon dont ils ont annoncé la
la dangerosité du régime des Poutine 3
plus une puissance nucléaire ça change
tout à la guerre les puissances
nucléaires ne s'attaquent pas
directement on doit en tirer de leçons
sur une guerre dans le Pacifique est-ce
que les États-Unis et la Chine pourront
s'affronter dans les États-Unis pour
Taïwan pour la défense de Taïwan alors
qu'ils sont tous les deux depuis son
nucléaires voilà une question que je
soumets au siège de tout poil mais j'ai
pas la réponse sans doute et fournir par
proxy un peu comme en Ukraine une guerre
régionale conséquence mondiale on se bat
uniquement à l'intérieur de l'Ukraine
mais ont tout le monde subit les
conséquences de cette guerre les crises
économiques la récession le chômage
on le voit bien et il y a pas que nous
il y a la crise humanitaire pour les
pays africains avec les céréales
nos armées tiennent leur place dans
l'OTAN l'OTAN est incontournable je
pense que c'est évident nos armées
tiennent leur place et nos armées
doivent tenir leur place dans l'OTAN je
reviendrai sur ce que je considère comme
un message très important sur le temps
dans la deuxième partie une guerre
1914-1940 j'appelle technologie avec des
choses très très modernes mais également
mais un esprit quand même très
soviétique pas une guerre du XXIe siècle
pas une guerre occidentale donc
attention le son qu'on va tirer pour une
guerre l'occidentale si tenter qu'on en
fassure parce qu'on peut aussi faire une
guerre comme ça pourquoi pas 10
enseignants militaires très rapidement
la surprise
surpris par les limites de l'armée russe
on ne connaissait pas l'armée russe
personne ne connaissait l'armée russe
personne ne connaît l'armée chinoise
l'armée chinoise on a une liste d'unités
impressionnantes 350 bateaux des
millions on l'a jamais vu combattre donc
une armée s'est au combat qu'elle se
juge c'est pas simplement sur une liste
d'équipements on l'a bien vu avec les
Ukrainiens l'incapacité des Russes à
utiliser leur American j'en ai parlé le
poids de la force morale l'importance de
la résilience de la nation que ce que
serait-il de la résilience de la France
d'ailleurs au terme de résilience qui
est très techno et très britannique je
préfère le terme de résistance qui veut
bien dire ce qui veut dire comment on
aurait résiste comment la nation
résisterait à une gare de ce type voilà
une bonne question qu'on doit se poser
l'important c'est l'antre de
l'entraînement de la guerre l'art de la
guerre et admirablement utilisé par les
Ukrainiens il y a pas d'autant toutes
les limites que j'ai raconté mais sont
très bien conseillés par les Occidentaux
une guerre l'importance du renseignement
du commandement des transmissions des
munitions de précision les Américains
les Russes sont très très peu de
munitions de précision ça c'est un
handicap majeur aujourd'hui l'OTAN la
force de l'Otan que ce soit on l'a vu
avec les highmars on le voit avec toutes
les bombes de l'aviation avec les
missiles de la marine ils sont toutes
une très grande précision nous n'avons
plus de munitions à dispersion une
munition un objectif une munition incoût
c'est ça qu'on doit rechercher et c'est
pour ça que les munitions coûtent plus
cher lorsqu'on devait tirer 250 obus
pour toucher un char un seul un seul
pardon une seule munition rodeuse qui va
coûter je sais pas 20000 euros un prix
au hasard et peut détruire un char plus
sûrement que une sable de 250 au but
canon qui vont arroser la zone
la première guerre de l'information la
vraie guerre de l'information la
première guerre des réseaux sociaux et
moi j'ai toujours mon téléphone je
connaissais pas Twitter j'aime pas du
tout Twitter mais je passe mon temps sur
Twitter si vous n'êtes pas sur Twitter
vous savez pas ce qui se passe et parce
que vous savez pas ce qui se passe vous
pouvez pas répondre et on nous demande
une réponse instantanée à tout ce qui se
passe on vous le demande à vous
responsable politique et c'est
impossible de le faire la guerre c'est
du temps long c'est du recul il faut
prendre de la hauteur on peut pas être
dans la gestion de chaque événement en
instantané
première guerre des drones n'a rien à
balle ça c'est un sujet majeur j'ai
maintenant dans les questions je
rappelle que c'est la première étape la
première étape ce sont des engins
pilotés par des hommes à distance la
deuxième étape à laquelle on échappera
pas ce sont des engins qui avec
l'intelligence artificielle choisiront
eux-mêmes leur objectif on sera assez
proche de la notion de robot j'en
parlerai on évitera pas la guerre des
robots on peut se rouler par terre on
peut dire que c'est pas possible que
c'est pas bien que c'est pas éthique
mais c'est comme ça que ça se passera
parce que c'est comme ça que nous
adversaires feront la guerre il faut
savoir si on veut gagner la guerre ou si
on veut faire une guerre électrique 100%
voilà peut-être un débat de réflexion
et puis dernier point sans attaquer
l'ennemi au sol c'est impossible de
gagner la guerre aujourd'hui il a
Ukrainiens je montrais dans les planches
ne n'attaque pas la Russie sur le sol
russe ils l'ont très peu attaqué au
début de la guerre dans quelques sites
de logistique ils ont créé quelques
frappes très limitées sur la Crimée
jamais avec des équipements occidentaux
et mis à part qui s'est passé il y a
deux jours avec des équipements
Ukrainiens ils vont se rappeler des
bases russes mais c'est évident que si
pour gagner la guerre pour que l'Ukraine
gagne la guerre contre la Russie il faut
qu'elle frappe le sol russe elle le
frappera pas le sur le russe elle ne
peut pas gagner la guerre en Ukraine de
la même manière que la Russie ne peut
pas gagner la guerre en Ukraine non plus
bon donc ça on en a un peu sur la
ensuite comment ça peut évoluer mais
pour des raisons différentes on se
concerne et enfin je termine par
celle-là enseignement stratégique
connaître ses adversaires intentions
capacités l'OTAN est incontournable la
France doit y prendre sa place toute sa
place
le temps c'est deux choses le temps
c'est une organisation militaire qui
sert à apprendre aux alliés à combattre
ensemble ça c'est bien
le temps c'est autre chose l'OTAN c'est
une organisation politique qui veut qui
peut se situer et qui peut avoir le
donner le sentiment de se situer une
espèce de Nations Unies occidentale qui
imposerait la loi occidentale au pays
qu'on jugerait non conformes à nos
principes donc je pense autant le temps
est un outil militaire indispensable et
la France il y a toute sa place autant
il faut faire attention à
l'instrumentalisation de l'OTAN l'OTAN
n'avait rien à faire en Afghanistan le
temps n'a rien à faire en Irak autant
n'aura rien à faire en adopacifique bon
on l'utilise parce qu'on a rien d'autre
mais vous posez la question est-ce qu'il
serait pas le temps d'avoir autre chose
que le temps pour faire des guerres qui
sont en dehors de la zone
euro-atlantique c'est le traité de
l'atlantineur c'est pas le traité du
Pacifique Sud or c'est vers ça que c'est
en train d'évoler gentiment avec toutes
les conséquences politiques que ça
comporte
l'addition nucléaire fonctionne pour les
attaquer la possède je pense que les
Ukrainiens ont dû amèrement regretter le
mémorandum de 94 là où ils ont rendu
leurs armes nucléaires contre la
protection de la communauté
internationale il serait une puissance
nucléaire jamais personne n'aurait
touché à l'Ukraine je pense que la Corée
du Nord l'Iran tous les pays qui sont
dit peut-être qu'il faut que j'ai une
arme nucléaire ça les conforte dans
l'idée que la dissuasion nucléaire
protège les États qui la possèdent la
France n'est pas prête pour une guerre
de haute intensité elle est pas prête
elle est pas prête du tout je pense que
vous le savez tous c'est pas le hasard
c'est simplement le fait qu'on n'a
jamais rentré la guerre intensité dans
le jeu dans le logiciel de nos
programmation militaire c'est un feu
c'est un constat c'est le chiffre prouve
bon nous n'avons donc pas les capacités
conventionnelles il y a un point qui est
important je pense que j'y reviendrai
mais je suis désolé mais c'est le
caractère dual de nos forces
conventionnelles et de nos forces
nucléaires
je vais prendre deux exemples l'exemple
de l'armée de l'air et l'exemple de la
Marine nationale notre ne force
militaire sont notre doctrine c'est est
taxé autour de la dissuasion nucléaire
nous avons une effort de dissuasion
nucléaire et des forces conventionnelles
mais à force de retraitir de compresser
le modèle d'armée on se retrouve avec
des forces des forces nucléaires qui
sont centrales et qui sont extrêmement
efficaces des sous-marins des rafales
des ravitailleurs mais la l'essentiel
des capacités de la marine et de l'armée
sont dual c'est-à-dire elles servent
soit elles servent à la fois les
décisions nucléaires et à la fois à la à
la guerre conventionnelle or lorsqu'on
va se trouver dans une situation de
tension maximum comme ça pratiquement
été le cas et bien il va falloir qu'on
sanctuarise nos capacités nucléaires
donc les capacités nucléaires propres
mais toutes les capacités
conventionnelles qui concourent à la
cohérence et donc on a plus grand shop
comme capacité conventionnelle en dehors
de l'armée de terre qui n'en prennent
pas dans le dans le jeu directement de
la dissuasion je reviendrai sur la
qu'est-ce qu'il nous faut pour la guerre
de intensité pour la guerre de la
tendance à une fois des fois ce
conventionnelle qui évite le
contournement de la dissuasion nucléaire
c'est vieux comme la fable de la
décision nucléaire c'est au cœur de la
décision nucléaire c'est dans les
premiers textes de la dissuasion
nucléaire les forces conventionnelles
évitent le contournement de la
destination nucléaire il permet au
président d'avoir une autre réponse de
la réponse nucléaire parce qu'on parle
la nucléaire c'est pas 0,1 on n'appuie
pas sur un bouton on va brancher 150
missiles il y a une gradation dans cette
gradation il faut que le président ait
des marges de manœuvre cela participe
directement de la crédibilité de la
dissuasion alors c'est un sujet
compliqué mais c'est un sujet important
je vais développer dans ce point là on a
quand même un atelier extraordinaire
alors la France également un rôle à
jouer puissance du Conseil de sécurité
on le sait acteur majeur de la
construction européenne une construction
européenne ambitieuse pas une
construction européenne qui qui veut
rester totalement subordonnée aux
Américains en tout cas ce que j'ai
compris la construction européenne qu'on
souhaite donc il nous faut des
transformer ambitieuses on a quand même
un atout extraordinaire c'est notre
industrie d'armement et ça vous le savez
parce que vous représentez des
territoires vous avez des régiments des
bases vous avez des industriels des PME
des grands groupes qui font vivre
l'économie française qui créent l'emploi
qui crée l'innovation et tout ça c'est
bon pour l'économie donc on a la chance
on n'est pas obligé d'acheter du
matériel aux États-Unis en Allemagne on
fait un brique 95% de nos matériaux en
France lyrique l'économie française
voilà parce que je terminais et je
m'excuse j'étais un peu long
assurance survie assurance vie c'est
important de comprendre ça assurance
survie assurance vie et donc monsieur le
Président je suis prêt à répondre aux
questions
merci mon général et vous avez pu
constater que tout le monde était très
attentif à votre présentation à votre
exposé le temps a peut-être été un peu
dépassé mais au moins concis compte tenu
de l'importance du sujet et je vous en
remercie j'ai une liste de questions ce
que je vous propose c'est de prendre les
questions toutes les questions et puis
de vous laisser le temps nécessaire pour
les réponses alors première question
Olivier cigolotti
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
général pardon merci déjà de cette
présentation très complète et très
instructive je souhaiterais
personnellement revenir sur les
faiblesses de la soi-disant redoutable
armée russe
dès les premières semaines de conflits
les problématiques de logistique ont
affaibli l'invasion russe et chacun se
souvient des des fils et des convois
militaires stationnés durant des jours
dans la capacités de progresser dans la
profondeur vous avez évoqué mon Général
également
l'engagement très incomplet de la faute
aérienne ou le stationnement d'aéronef
ces derniers jours sur le tarmac de de
base militaire ce qui démontre un
certain nombre de faiblesses alors
est-ce qu'il s'agit de faiblesses
capacitaires de lacune opérationnelle je
pense qu'il s'agit peut-être des deux
mais doit-on déduire qu'il existe
d'importantes lacunes en termes de
doctrine d'emploi
ou comme vous l'avez évoqué des maillons
faibles ou inexistants dans les
différentes chaînes de commandement on
peut se poser la question au vu
effectivement de ces de ces difficultés
régulièrement constatées et puis
deuxième point que vous avez évoqué mais
sur lequel nous sommes peut-être passé
un peu vite vous l'avez dit ce qui s'est
passé le 5 décembre c'est-à-dire lundi
dernier constitue un tournant puisque le
territoire russe n'avait pas été attaqué
depuis 1944 et les Ukrainiens ont osé
avec des drones vous l'avez dit bricoler
attaquer le territoire russe est-ce que
ce n'est pas une ultime provocation de
voladie merzuelinski pour donner un
nouveau tournant à ce conflit ukrainien
merci mon général
seconde question François Bonnot
oui merci président
mon général
à la lumière de ce que nous vivons et
observons depuis huit mois
que pensez-vous qu'il serait nécessaire
pour la France pour renforcer sa défense
entre entière aérienne
à travers le fait que la France a
surtout ces dernières années
étaient en présence de conflits
asymétriques et par ailleurs que
pensez-vous qu'il manque à l'Ukraine
toujours en termes de défense antérienne
pour arrêter davantage de des missiles
qui arrivent sur son sol
merci troisième question Cédric Perrin
qui est l'un des rapporteurs du RETEX
merci
en général il y aurait évidemment une
multitude de questions que j'aimerais
vous poser mais peut-être qu'on le fera
dans le cadre dans un cadre plus
restreint avec les mon corps apporterait
et un certain nombre de personnes mais
plusieurs choses première question c'est
d'abord le début de cette guerre on nous
on nous explique depuis un certain temps
que
l'artillerie a repris ses lettres de
noblesse parce que évidemment
aujourd'hui on voit l'importance qu'elle
revait avec un certain nombre de
matériel les Césars les imams et
compagnie certains disent que si
l'artillerie reprend ses lettres
noblesse c'est aussi parce que les
Russes ont fait une erreur monumentale
au départ en considérant cette affaire
comme une guerre de quelques jours et en
opérant pas comme la doctrine
occidentale de vaudrait c'est-à-dire en
bombardant les zones
j'allais dire vitales au pavital mais en
tout cas les zones qui permettraient qui
permettent aujourd'hui aux Ukrainiens de
leur répondre est-ce que d'abord est-ce
que ça vous pense est-ce que ça vous
paraît vous aussi quelque chose de
logique mais certains disent aussi que
en toute état de cause compte tenu de
l'état de l'aviation russe de son
hétérogénéité j'allais dire en termes de
matériel mais aussi de la faiblesse de
la formation des pilotes russes qui ne
sont finalement formés qu'à savoir
décoller atterrir en toute sécurité sans
avoir de
d'opérations qui les ont aguerris
auraient de toute façon
fait échouer un raid aérien russe ça
c'est ma première question et la
deuxième question c'est combien de temps
peut durer un conflit sous le parapluie
nucléaire dans un confident lequel les
deux belligérants retiennent leur coût
Vladimir Poutine a parlé on sait très
bien que pour la dissuasion il faut
évidemment de la crédibilité une
résolution politique sans faille à une
communication qui permette en tout cas
de d'asseoir cette cette résolution
politique mais Poutine a parlé d'intérêt
vitaux il a notamment dit il y a
quelques mois que si des missiles
touchés le territoire russe ces
interviews seraient attaqués dans ce
cas-là il rétorquerait enfin il
répondrait de manière radicale qu'est-ce
que vous pensez de tout ça et ce
qu'aujourd'hui l'attaque lise les
attaques récentes de ces jours-ci de
virus des
Ukrainiens me semble-t-il sur les bases
aériennes russes sont pour vous en tout
cas
des affaires les intérêts vitaux russes
atteint merci merci Cédric Olivier Cadic
maintenant
aussi président merci mon général pour
ce partage d'analyse juste une petite
nuance lors de l'invasion puisque nous
sommes allés au mois d'avril à Kiev
c'est l'intelligence artificielle qui a
permis de repérer d'éliminer les forces
spéciales russes projetées sur Kiev lors
de l'invasion destinale neutraliser
zelinsky donc c'est il y a quand même eu
je tiens des choses nouvelles sur ce
conflit je voulais vous interroger sur
la capacité de renouvellement des forces
russes le présent Poutine a lancé un
ordre de mobilisation des forces des
réserves quel impact d'après vous parce
que on a quand même des informations
comme quoi beaucoup sont partis de
Russie et surtout quels sont ces marges
de manœuvre à l'avenir pour dans ce
domaine est-ce qu'il a une possibilité
de d'aller plus loin et de mobiliser
plus de monde et alors ça vous dites à
la fin et gouverner ses prévoir vous
allez totalement raison et vous nous
dites que la France de votre point de
vue n'est pas prête pour une guerre de
haute intensité puisque il faut prévoir
d'après vous quel pays est prêt pour une
guerre de haute intensité aujourd'hui
merci président général vous êtes
général d'armée aérienne donc je
voudrais axer mon intervention sur ce
sujet vous avez montré le 121ème
régiment de Bombardier russe on imagine
assez facilement que finalement c'est
bombardiers peuvent régulièrement venir
la frontière engager des tirs on l'a vu
que dans d'autres guerres que ce soit en
Libye que ce soit en série que ce soit
pendant la guerre 40 aussi
du côté américain comme font comme
allemand l'importance de l'aviation pour
gagner la guerre et il nous semble que
on l'a l'occurrence
comprendre un peu mieux pourquoi
finalement les Russes naxent pas
davantage leurs attaques de cette
manière là parce que dans un climat
comme le aujourd'hui extrêmement froid
plus vous bombardez plus vous
affaiblissez en face les troupes puis
j'imagine qu'on a des capacités de tirer
une précision de tir plus avec les
images satellites qui pourraient abréger
rapidement
les chances de cette de cette guerre
alors pourquoi c'est d'abord pas dans
cette voie là
pouvez-vous nous en dire plus
en général vous avez conseillé pendant 8
ans le PDG de Dassault Éric Rapier qui
préside également le Conseil des
industries de défense française
pensez-vous que ces industriels sont
prêts à entrer dans une nouvelle ère de
production et comment l'État peut-il les
accompagner et puis finalement
l'opinion russe semble s'inverser
sérieusement en ce moment n'est ce pas
là la véritable arme qui arrêtera
Poutine
et merci président merci général pour
eux les informations que vous avez bien
voulu vous donner mais dans votre
intervention et à la fois des aspects
militaires mais aussi d'autres aspects
qui ne sont pas communitaires et qui
sont politiques aussi au sens noble du
terme avant de poser ma question je veux
revenir sur deux
éléments que vous avez évoqués en disant
ce qui n'est pas faux que Twitter
aujourd'hui permet instantanéité
certes mais le fait de prendre le temps
de la réflexion et aussi important selon
moi que l'instantanéité et donc les deux
peuvent aller de perches je pense que
nous serons d'accord
alors en général certes nous lisons pas
dans un monde de bisounours vous avez
dit à un moment donné le but de la
guerre c'est de faire des morts
je conteste ce point de vue
parce que on peut très bien faire la
guerre en étant pas obsédé par le fait
de faire des marques on a dit en
attaquant sur le plan militaire en ayant
des frères qui peuvent être stratégiques
pour éventuellement diminuer
l'adversaire mais ça nécessairement
considéré que le but c'est de faire
absolument des morts
il y a 40000 morts civils semblent-ils
est-ce que vous avez connaissance du
nombre de civils Ukrainiens qui sont qui
sont morts du fait de ces guerres et du
nombre de civils russes qui sont morts
du fer de cette guerre du fait de cette
guerre
ces deux chiffres là permettraient
l'avoir un éclairage sur cet aspect là
enfin
dernièrement vous avez parlé dans votre
intervention du fait que nous étions à
nouveau un tournant de cette guerre ça
fait plusieurs mois qu'à chaque fois on
dit une somme à un tournant donc c'est
le dernier tournant mais il est
important c'est le fait que les
Ukrainiens aient frappé en territoire
russe
les États-Unis aujourd'hui ou hier ont
indiqué qu'ils ne soutenaient pas ce
type d'intervention
ukrainien
pensez-vous que la possibilité de
frapper sur le territoire ukrainien et
précisément sur ces trois
objectifs militaires et puis se réaliser
d'une part sans avoir une bonne
connaissance du renseignement
spatial de la part des Américains d'une
part et d'autre part quant à sa
réalisation que cela puisse se faire
sans le soutien précis des États-Unis
d'Amérique
des soutiens et de soutien précis
logistique pour permettre d'atteindre la
cible pour être précis
merci dernière question huxory
président mon général avec plusieurs
milliers de satellites de satellite
militaire et civile en orbite dont
certains participent militaires ou
civils à cette guerre avec des
lancements chaque année toujours plus
nombreux et des constellations de
plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
satellites en construction le milieu
spatial stratégique et particulièrement
compétitif vous pouvez vous nous
expliquer la place des satellites dans
cette guerre et les différentes missions
auxquelles il participe enfin vous
est-il possible d'esquisser la façon
dont ces missions sont appelées à
évoluer dans l'avenir je vous remercie
alors ce n'était pas la dernière j'ai
une question aussi de Jean-Marc
todeschnique qui est le second
rapporteur de la rétex oui je vais très
rapide en général on parle de guerre de
haute intensité à votre avis est-ce que
la France peut s'y préparer en dehors
d'une coalition
l'OTAN le président de la République
avait dit qui avait l'OTAN était avait
un encéphalogramme plat je partageais ce
qu'il avait dit à l'époque mais on voit
bien que ce qui se passe en Ukraine a
fait remonter
les forces au sein de l'OTAN et en
Europe
je pense que on a encore un peu de temps
et beaucoup de temps avant de voir une
réelle Europe de la défense organisée on
est à la merci des Américains qui
peuvent du jour au lendemain décidaient
de repartir comme ils l'ont fait
dans d'autres conflits est-ce que la
France est peu elle se préparait toute
seule à cette guerre de haute intensité
deuxième question là vous général de
l'armée de l'air faut-il à l'approche de
la LPM faut-il continuer à réfléchir en
avion en bateau en canon ou de faut-il
pas complètement changé de je dirais de
boussole pour réfléchir on voit bien ce
qui s'est passé au Carabasse ce qui se
passe ailleurs avec les drones peut-on
encore réfléchir de la même façon
dans le cadre de la préparation de
de cet LPM qui va définir pour un
certain nombre d'années les équipements
de force
voilà et dernière question cette fois-ci
Guillaume Gontard
merci monsieur le Président
je voulais revenir sur ce que vous avez
dit sur une guerre de type 14-18 ou 39
45 et qu'on n'était pas dans une guerre
du 21e siècle et je voulais savoir
qu'est-ce que c'est réellement qu'une
guerre du 21e siècle et une guerre à
l'occidentale parce que c'est vrai qu'on
entend souvent ce type de propos et puis
vous dites également que que l'Ukraine
ne peut gagner que si elle si elle
frappe en Russie et moi je pense qu'à
l'inverse ça serait une ouverture du
conflit et plutôt une extension de de ce
conflit donc est-ce que vous pourriez un
peu mieux expliquer justement ce que
vous voyez par là parce que j'arrive un
peu du mal à comprendre
l'évolution pourrait avoir le conflit
par ses frappes justement côté
ukrainien merci
voilà mon Général dit 10 questions et
vous noterez qu'aucune collègue féminine
n'a posé de questions
voilà c'est trop sérieux je vais finir
par croire que karagon a définitivement
raison et que la femme et l'avenir de
l'homme ça c'est pas une question pour
vous vous avez la parole
alors premier point concernant les
faiblesses de l'armée russe les
faiblesses capacitaires et d'autres
d'emploi je l'évoquais en fait cette
armée russe ressemble plus à une non
armée russe qui a une armée russe parce
que le plus puissant de la marine de
l'armée russe et la marine russe et la
marine russe n'a pas été engagée pour
plein de raisons parce que
j'ai craignant pas de marine l'armée de
l'air russe et puissante et foncé rose
spatiale sont puissantes mais elles ne
sont pas entraînées n'ont pas d'heures
de vol elles ne sont pas suffisamment
modernisées ils n'ont pas de mission de
précision les Russes comme les Chinois
connaissent la doctrine occidentale et
ils essaient de la repiquer dans de la
repiquer dans leur document dans leur
doctrine mais malheureusement ils n'ont
pas la technique ils n'ont pas les
moyens de faire la gagne centraine pas
la façon dont les Occidentaux
s'entraînent l'armée russe a plein de
problèmes des problèmes qui sont liés à
sa nature même à son fonctionnement à la
corruption qui mine l'armée russe qui a
miné l'armée russe depuis 30 ans au
clientélisme à tout ce système
russe qui a un système
mafieux politique et qui commence par
Poutine et qui va jusqu'en bas donc
violence corruption manque
d'entraînement il y a sans doute des
pépites dans la mer russe toute la mer
russe n'est pas n'est pas uniforme mais
elle n'est pas prête à faire la guerre
la seule guerre qu'on l'a vu faire c'est
en Afghanistan on a dû commencer à se
terminer alors c'est pas forcément la
faute des rues sont peut-être pas plus
mauvais que les que les Américains c'est
c'est simplement qu'il ne s'entraîne pas
la seule guerre qu'ils ont fait de
sérieuse c'est la Syrie et en Syrie bah
on mettait des membres des stratégies
qui m'ont parlé tout le monde et après
on envoyait les soldats de cadiro faire
la police et garder les grandes
prisonniers voilà et on mettait les
Forces Spéciales donc en fait voilà la
question de l'entraînement la création
de la du bon concept de la préparation
des bons équipements c'est ça qui est
clé on peut dire que les Occidentaux
savent faire on a la bonne doctrine le
bon concept les bons niveaux
d'entraînement on sait travailler entre
tous les différents militaires amers la
russes ne servent pas on est capable de
faire
l'OTAN la France avec des sources de
commandes françaises on est capable de
gérer des sorties plusieurs sorties de
centaines d'avions par jour pendant des
semaines pour une campagne aérienne les
Russes n'ont pas la technique ils ont
pas les outils de planification pour
faire ça donc toutes ces déficiences et
en fait tout le système le système russe
dans lequel tout le monde mange tout le
monde donc les militaires romantiques et
la vérité c'est le combat la vérité
c'est le jour où il faut y aller c'est
là que ce jeu armée et c'est là que
l'armée russe était jugé et que
paradoxalement
ultime provocation
ukrainienne
de lundi l'affaire de lundi l'affaire de
cette espèce de contre-offensive des
Russes elle est difficile à analyser
d'abord je le dis il est clair que que
la ligne rouge des des Occidentaux c'est
de dire on vous donne de l'armement vous
avez pas le droit de frapper la Russie
vous avez même pas le droit de frapper
la Crimée les quelques rares frappes
qu'il y a eu sur la Crimée ont été
faites avec des armements
Ukrainiens soviétique en tout cas pas
des armements occidentaux donc cette
limite elle est mis elle est mise parce
que la priorité est la seule priorité
des Occidentaux des Américains mais je
pense également et c'est dit comme ça du
président Macron et de l'OTAN c'est de
ne pas aller jusqu'à le confrontation en
direct entre l'OTAN et la Russie parce
que la Russie a signé le tête nucléaire
c'est pas très compliqué à comprendre ça
donc tout le monde le comprend sauf que
c'est un ski ça intéresse pas et c'est
normal que ça intéresse pas c'est pas
son sujet lui son sujet c'est la survie
de l'Ukraine donc c'est l'un ce qu'est
une stratégie qui effectivement a
tendance à pousser les limites au-delà
de ce l'occidentaux accepte mais ces
stratégies c'est deux occidentaux de qui
ont des contacts réguliers avec Zelinski
de faire en sorte que c'est pour ça
qu'on arrive à un moment où cette guerre
devient extrêmement inquiétante
les positions se gèle sur la ligne de
frontières avec l'hiver il y a des
bombardements massifs des populations
ukrainiennes qui vont souffrir tout
l'hiver de manière insupportable et puis
vous avez des contre-attaques sur la
Russie les highmars le fameux missile
des highmars que les Américains refusent
de livrer là s'appelle la taxe qui est
un missile un peu particulier il a une
portée de 300 miles ça fait 450 km de
l'Ukraine il peut taper Moscou voilà
donc les Américains on peut pas dire
tenez ça puis aussi jamais vous allez
taper Moscou on dirait que c'est pas
nous donc on est dans même dans une
guerre tout à fait incroyable dans
lequel il y a l'aide il y a la retenue
en permanence l'aide et la retenue
l'aide et la retenue posez un ski y a
pas de retenue faut y aller il est dans
son rôle il est dans son rôle c'est à la
communauté internationale de prendre ses
responsabilités vous comprenez bien là
la question donc effectivement la frappe
de la Russie je pense qu'il va y avoir
des représailles très sérieuses de la
part des
avec encore des missiles qui vont tomber
sur l'Ukraine en grande quantité la
question du seuil nucléaire moi je
l'aborde tout de suite parce qu'elles
étaient plus ou moins évoquées moi j'y
crois pas j'y crois pas parce qu'en fait
imaginons imaginons que la Russie tire
une arme nucléaire de faible puissance
sur l'Ukraine le monde s'arrête le monde
s'est arrêté 15 jours parce que la reine
d'Angleterre est morte alors une bombe
qui explose en Europe même de faible
puissance mais d'un coup tout le monde
s'arrête on coupe tout on allume la
télévision arrêtez moi tout ça donc à la
limite il le ferait pour geler les
positions mais je pense qu'il a trouvé
mieux que ça pour gérer les positions
c'est-à-dire il y avait un excès la
partie de l'Ukraine qui contrôle ou tout
au parti de ce qui contrôle c'est la
campagne de bombardements massif c'est
une forme de dame nucléaire
conventionnelle il va obliger les
Ukrainiens à courber les Chine sur ses
attaques nombreuses mais les ukraines on
pense dans son cambody la Chine la
question ça va être notre Chine à nous
est-ce qu'on va la courber ou pas sur ce
sujet
donc je sais pas si j'ai déclare là
dessus défense antillais évidemment il y
a des il y a des manques dans l'armée
française qui sont cri la défense
antiérienne c'est catastrophique
un excellent système qui s'appelle le
mobile SAMTECH qui sert à défendre nos
bases aériennes il est très performant
d'abord défense antériennes c'est
compliqué parce qu'il y a plusieurs
couches donc pour contrôler de 0 à 50 km
il vous faut 4 systèmes différents et
puis comme le comme le champ de bataille
est grand il faut en mettre partout donc
en fait c'est un investissement majeur
qu'on n'a pas fait je pense qu'il faut
renforcer nos capacités en matière de
défense antérienne bien évidemment on
est très loin du compte pour une guerre
doit être intensité en ce qui concerne
l'artillerie il faut pas tirer de
mauvais enseignements de cette guerre ça
veut pas dire qu'on a trop d'artillerie
nous n'avons pas assez d'artillerie
soyons clairs l'un des Français c'est 50
canons César 70 canons César si on est
sympa c'est je crois qu'il y a on le
sait bien le premier régiment
d'artillerie c'est dit lance-roquette
unitaire on les appelle une tiers parce
qu'on a peur de les appeler multiples
mais c'est dans ce cas multiples on en a
10 et cela dit si on a trois qui
fonctionnent bon c'est pas avec ça qu'on
va gagner la guerre je peux vous parler
des rafales je parlais des frégates je
vais de toutes ces forces
conventionnelles qui ne sont pas
suffisantes pour faire une guerre de
haute intensité donc la question c'est
on a besoin de tout en réalité et je
reviens sur la question est-ce qu'on a
besoin de compter des bateaux des
rafales des machins oui on a besoin
d'augmenter la masse mais on a également
besoin de faire des efforts dans tous
les domaines de guerre la cyber le
renseignement les drones alors un petit
un petit mot rapide sur les drones là
vous avez vu j'ai montré une image je
vais leur montrer parce que je pense
qu'elle est intéressante si j'arrive à
revenir sur cette image c'est le fameux
TB2 et où le TB2 ce qui est au milieu là
le TB2 pourquoi on n'a pas de drone en
France parce qu'on n'a pas d'industriel
adapté à ce type d'objet c'est pas
d'assaut ou c'est pas Airbus qui va
faire des drones qui coûtent 2 millions
d'euros alors qu'ils font des avions
c'est pas là qui vont gagner de l'argent
donc et comme on a tué toutes nos
entreprises de taille intermédiaires
c'est pas non plus une PME qui peut
faire ça donc il faut des ETI il faut
trouver une ETI française qui est
capable de faire ce type d'objet un TB2
ça vaut à la louche à 2 millions de
dollars trois drônes Reaper américain
que tu es AR qui soit la gamme au dessus
ça vaut 140 millions de dollars les
trois bon donc il nous faut
effectivement avoir la quantité
peut-être diminuer la techno dans
certains domaines on a des capacités
dont on a besoin et qui nous manquent
évidemment pour faire la guerre doit
être intensité donc c'est un c'est
vraiment un sujet compliqué important il
faut tout il faut conserver les
capacités que l'on a puissantes et
polyvalente un point important une frame
c'est polyvalent un Rafale c'est
polyvalent ça fait de la haute de la
basse et de la haute un Charles Leclerc
c'est pas polyvalent comme vous voyez le
but de 155 il y a 155 mm qui partent
donc il nous faut des chars Leclerc il
nous faut des canons il nous faut des
moyens polyvalents les plus ça serait
polyvalent et mieux c'est évidemment moi
je pense par exemple en ce qui concerne
d'artillerie la guerre de demain la
guerre en particulier une guerre telle
qu'on la voit ce sont c'est une guerre
de de tir de longue portée que ce soit
par des sous-marins que ce soit par des
avions que ce soit par le sol c'est de
la langue portée aujourd'hui le
principal investissement que font les
armées américaines l'US Navy US Air
Force et l'usmi c'est dans les missiles
et personnel longue distance il prévoit
une guerre de missiles de longues
distances contre la Chine on va essayer
de tout taper les bateaux les bases ça
va être une guerre de missibles longue
distance ça a pas une garde de tranchée
d'artillerie à coup de distance c'est de
cette guerre là c'est cette guerre là
que les Américains préparent pour demain
donc cette guerre là effectivement c'est
celle aussi qu'il faut qu'on considère
mais elle nécessite des moyens qui sont
sans doute très supérieurs à ceux qui
ont à ce que notre budget autorise donc
il faut être raisonnable mais là on est
passé en dessous de la ligne de
flottaison concernant nos armées
conventionnelles je pense que d'ailleurs
il y a tous les chefs d'état-major que
que vous audité ils vous le disent et
vous lisent pas comme ça parce qu'il
peut pas vous le dire comme ça mais
c'est ce qu'ils vous disent ils le
disent loyalement en accord avec le
pouvoir politique parce que nos chefs
militaire ont une qualité essentielle
c'est qu'ils sont loyaux
donc ils acceptent les moyens qu'on leur
donne et font le maximum avec les moyens
qu'on le donne en fonction des missions
qui leur ont ordonné et ça c'est
vraiment une des forces de l'armée
française
j'avais une question
Poutine les intérêts vitaux les intérêts
vitaux de Poutine on a bien elle revient
à la question nucléaire vous savez vous
souvenez que la directrice nationale du
renseignement qui s'appelle
qui supervise les 17 agences de
renseignement américain a été auditée
par le par le Sénat français au mois de
juin elle a dit il y a deux cas dans
lequel on peut imaginer que Poutine peut
utiliser l'arme nucléaire tactique le
premier c'est si jamais par la guerre
se fait expulser de il peut pas faire
autre chose que que de mettre une arme
nucléaire pour faire baisser la tête à
tout le monde et le deuxième s'il y a un
changement de régime en Russie alors je
réponds à la question sur est-ce que
Poutine et fragile Poutine n'est pas
fragile
je pense qu'on aimerait qu'il soit
fragile ça c'est certain on aimerait
qu'il y a un coup d'État que on met un
bon démocrate à la place au programme ça
va rester au pouvoir jusqu'à la fin ne
serait-ce que à partir du moment la
guerre seradicalise et que ça devient
une guerre où la Russie est attaquée
mais la nation russe elle va se
regrouper autre chose et soldats qui
meurent ou tu sais généraux ou sur son
chef d'État donc de ce point de vue là
l'attaque direct de la Russie par
l'Ukraine ça va peut également réveiller
le sentiment national ça peut également
réveiller peut-être des troupes dans la
Russie mais c'est possible aussi mais
les deux sont possibles
si jamais
alors la Crimée je pense que la Crimée
fait partie des intérêts plutôt de la
Russie je pense que les Américains l'ont
identifié comme ça donc d'ailleurs vous
entendez que le discours cela crimait
même le président et la comparé avec on
sait que c'est pas tout à fait la maison
quand même donc même ce sujet mais il y
a quand même il faut bien comprendre
mais vous savez parce qu'il y a ce qu'on
dit puis ce qui se passe il y a les
annonces qu'on fait parce qu'il est
important que les Occidentaux
n'affichent pas leur stratégie vis-à-vis
des Russes donc il y a effectivement un
langage officiel et en fait des
négociations qui qui sont pas forcément
et équivalentes au langage officiel je
pense que tout le monde a compris
comment fonctionne la diplomatie donc
oui la Crimée cette partie des intérêts
vitaux je pense que Poutine ne laissera
pas la Crimée tomber c'est vraiment on
est passé dans le symbole intérêt vital
symbole on a vu sa réaction avec des
pointières et puis et puis deuxième
sujet si jamais balancent un théu 141
sur Moscou là c'est sûr que
et je pense pas qu'il le fasse mais je
ne sais pas enfin voilà on sait pas
c'est on sait pas ce que tout est
possible dans ces guerres en tout cas je
pense qu'on a un moment très dangereux
de cette guerre on est à un moment
particulièrement dangereux de cette
guerre je pense qu'il faut qu'on en soit
tout conscient
je vais pas oublier de questions les
forces russes mobilisation impact la
mobilisation est très importante je
pense que le 300000 il a quand même
réussi à en récupérer un bon centaine de
milliers faut pas croire qu'il y a que
des trains de savate dans la
merveilleuse il y a des jeunes qui
veulent se battre pour la Russie aussi
ils sont pas bien organisés c'est la
catastrophe administrative c'est la
Russie quoi c'est un mélange d'Union
soviétique et de et de démocratie ratée
donc ça fonctionne mal mais néanmoins
ils envoient quand même des solutions
sur le front il commence à arriver à les
équiper péniblement il a une réserve
considérable si jamais Poutine déclare
la guerre mobilisation générale je peux
me la donnée 3 millions 4 millions
d'hommes ils seront ils seront équipés
avec ce qu'ils peuvent mais donc en fait
cet arbre de la mobilisation c'est son
arme nucléaire c'est la deuxième arme
nucléaire la première marque nucléaire
passer l'arme de guerre tactique la
deuxième c'est passé en guerre et
mobilisation générale on passe en école
de guerre je pense pas qu'il le fera
parce que l'Ukraine ça quand même pas
cette importance pour la Russie la
Russie n'est pas attaquée elle essaie
l'attaque un pays et bon il prend une
partie c'est pas tout à fait la même
chose
mais ça c'est un avis personnel et
vraiment il est tout à fait subjectif et
vous avez tous fait le droit d'avoir le
même j'ai pas plus d'éléments vous
pourrons juger les bons virus
l'importance de l'aviation oui c'est
vraiment une surprise incroyable
pourquoi cette aviation est hyper
puissante a été si mal utilisée c'est
pas ce qu'ils savent pas faire ils
savent comment il faut faire ils savent
ceux qui faut faire ils recopie copier
coller la doctrine américaine mais il
s'entraîne pas ils ont pas les outils
ils n'ont pas les mécaniques ils ont pas
les chefs pour ça ils ont pas les
structures de les carottes la mécanique
de la planification de la boucle
j'observe je détecte je tire une savent
pas faire ça il s'entraîne pas ils sont
mauvais je vois plus simple ils sont
mauvais donc alors que les Ukrainiens
ils sont pas nombreux ils sont bons donc
vous voyez il faut il compense leur
sous-effectif et leur sous-équipement
par une excellente gestion de leurs
moyens grâce à la formation des
Occidentaux et grâce au conseil je pense
aussi d'être donc grâce à leur bravo
alors courage moi j'ai pas d'autres là
dessus
le GIFAS la nouvelle aire de production
comment les industriels peuvent aider
je pense que moi j'ai passé 7 ans dans
l'industrie
j'ai pas regretté parce que j'ai appris
des choses et je pense que les officiers
généraux
enfin tout intérêt à découvrir c'est pas
dans l'industrie parce qu'évidemment
c'est un enjeu majeur pour la défense
pour la France pour la défense et le
lien grosso modo je vais le simplifier
le lien entre la DGA l'industriel et les
armées il est bon il est excellent ça
c'est la paire de base on a industrie
qui est performante on a une déjà qui
fait le job on a des militaires qui
commencent à comprendre les engins
industriels donc tout ça ça paquet
complet après industriel c'est pas
compliqué ça évite commande vous voulez
passer des commandes des produits vous
lui passez pas des commandes il produit
pas c'est pas c'est pas du bénévolat
donc pourquoi nos industriels il faut
bien voir que nos industriels on survécu
c'est un miracle on a encore des
industriels de l'armement parce qu'ils
ont été malmenés comme toutes les
industries depuis 30 ans des commandes
family que des cadences ralenties ils
ont vécu grâce à l'export et
heureusement qu'elle explore et
heureusement qu'ils ont la masse de
l'export qui permet de faire tourner
leur mais
ne tient qu'à nous de passer des
commandes pour que ils aient des
plancharges et j'ai de la perspective
ils puissent recruter et produire des
armements qui sont qui qui iront dans
nos armées et qui iront vers l'export
dans les armées étrangères et de ce
point de vue là soit il conscients des
fêtes qu'on ne sait tout faire sauf le
fusil d'assaut puisqu'on a demandé aux
Allemands de faire des filets d'assaut
bon d'accord mais on sait pratiquement
tout faire sauf les drones le fameux
drone mal là le rhodrone qui est on peut
dire la conséquence d'une coopération
extrêmement difficile entre Airbus
l'Allemagne d'assaut les Espagnols les
Italiens je peux commencer enfin le
droit nous l'attend depuis 20 ans et
puis on leur en 2030 encore 10 ans bon
on n'est pas pressé vous avez dire si on
est pressé on est pressé parce que ce
type de drone comme le droit au drone
vous le faites voler au-dessus de
l'Ukraine au-dessus de la Russie il
reste en vol 5 minutes
c'est un vol de guerre asymétrique c'est
un vol pour barkhane c'est un vol pour
avant et après la guerre c'est pas un
drone pour pendant la guerre pour
pendant la guerre faut soit des drones
consommables pas chers qui vont faire 4
missions en tirant quelques bombes ils
seront détruits mais c'est pas grave ça
coûte des millions d'euros c'est le cas
du ptb2 soit des drones de combat et là
c'est un autre domaine là on rentre dans
l'aviation de combat qui a été évoqué
par l'un d'entre vous demain les pays il
y aura deux types de pays il y aura les
riches et les Parisiens les riches c'est
à dire la Chine et la Russie et pas dans
la Chine est unique auront toute la
panne de plus complète d'avion piloté de
drone de ton type piloté au papilloter
et puis il y a les autres ce qui vous
ont choisi entre des technologies un peu
anciennes mais modernisées et et la et
ce mouvement vers les droits de moi je
suis persuadé et je le dis vraiment si
vraiment j'ai une conviction aujourd'hui
c'est qu'on échappera pas la guerre des
drones là c'est mathématique c'est c'est
la technologie c'est la technologie qui
qui poussent les les concepts qui
poussent l'armement et la guerre des
drones c'est la guerre de terrestre
navale sous-marin satellite elles
annonces spatiaux derrière commencer les
drognes il y en a partout cette guerre a
le hokaraba qui avait été un signal vous
l'avez dit cette guerre on a commencé
avec très peu de drone on va terminer
avec des milliers de drones de tout type
et tout le monde veut terrestre
sous-marin aérien petit gros moyens tout
voilà bon donc ça évidemment il faut
essayer de le cadrer on peut faire des
comités d'éthique bien sûr c'est utile
mais faut pas s'imaginer que les autres
vont faire des comités d'éthique
ça m'amène à un point sur la guerre qui
était est-ce que est-ce que pour faire
une guerre propre il faut bien
comprendre que le concept de zéro mort
qui est le concept des Américains qui
ont essayé d'exporter c'est zéro mort de
leur côté de l'autre côté mais c'est pas
zéro mort en face hein parce qu'en face
la guerre de 91 la première guerre
d'Irak on s'est toujours pas combien il
y a une mort quand il y aura car ce
qu'on sait c'est qu'il y a eu 98000
tonnes de bombes qui ont été versés sur
la sur Bagdad à côté normalement ça dû
faire un peu plus qu'une dizaine de
morts
donc je par contre je peux peut-être
commenter un élément sur la guerre
propre c'est la question du droit
international humanitaire la question
des conventions bien sûr il faut des
conventions il faut savoir que les
conventions elles ont des conséquences
sur nos forces exemple je reviens au
premier régiment d'artillerie le
lance-roquette il avait 57 dans ce cas
de multiples en 2010 57 entre 4
multiples c'était des requêtes à
dispersion de Grenade donc il y a des
repères à sous-munition en 2008 la
convention d'Oslo interdit les recettes
à ce munitions on cite la Convention on
transforme nos 57 lance-roquettes
multiples en 13 lance-roquette unitaire
non seulement 300 opérationnels
bien sûr qu'il faut appliquer les le
droit de la guerre mais le droit de la
guerre a des conséquences sur le coût
des munitions donc ça veut dire que
plutôt que de lancer une mission pas
cher qui va dépasser des grenades on va
faire une mission comme celle du
lance-roquette unitaire qui va coûter
plusieurs centaines de milliers d'euros
donc les lois de la guerre ça des
conséquences également sur le coût de la
guerre ça c'est important ça veut pas
dire faut pas les respecter ça veut dire
que toutes les lois de la guerre ont été
faites après les grandes guerres pas
avant les grandes gars voilà je termine
parce que j'ai fini peut-être le dernier
point
le temps de réflexion les 40000 morts
les frappes territorius j'en ai parlé la
question des satellites je suis pas
compétent il y a évidemment une guerre
de satellite les satellites sont
essentiels dans tous les domaines côté
américain côté russe les Russes les
utilisent mais il y a pas de
confrontation il y a pas d'agressivité
de la part des deux c'est évidemment une
dimension indispensable du renseignement
au même type que la guerre électronique
au même type que les écoutes
électroniques
tout au début tout est au début de la
guerre au début de la guerre il y a
effectivement des satellites qui ont été
agressés par les Russes mais dès que la
guerre a commencé il y a eu vraiment une
grande attention à l'agressivité est-ce
qu'on ferait une guerre de haute
intensité toute seule évidemment non
c'est hors de question on fera forcément
une guerre avec le temps la question
c'est quel sera la place que la France
veut tenir dans une guerre dirigée par
les Américains dans le temps est-ce
qu'on veut continuer à être 4% comme on
l'a été dans toutes les guerres qu'on a
fait jusqu'à présent dans les conditions
américaine où est-ce que finalement la
France puissance nucléaire monte pas
moins de conseils de sécurité
pays qui a des ambitions de la
construction européenne mérite pas un
petit peu plus que 4% dans la guerre
dirigée par les Américains il faut faire
des efforts dans ce sens-là moi mon
sentiment c'est qu'il faut faire des
efforts dans le domaine conventionnel et
bien étudier cette question de la
dualité des moyens dédiés au nucléaire
et des moyens qui sont non dédiés au
nucléaires pour trouver un équilibre
plus favorable à la guerre de la
tendanceité enfin avion bateau je
répondu effectivement il faut changer de
logiciel mais malheureusement le
processus d'acquisition est difficile à
changer les militaires je connais bien
il passe tellement de temps à se battre
sur la LPM ils ont du mal à regarder
loin devant c'est difficile de voir le
Alain il faut du temps pour garder loin
donc il faut qu'on les aide que la DGA
que les industriels que les signes tanks
les aide à regarder loin de l'an et puis
une guerre du 20e siècle une guerre
occidentale c'est quoi c'est une guerre
où il y a beaucoup beaucoup plus de
technologie ou il y a beaucoup de cyber
ou il y a beaucoup de de mouvements des
satellites où il y aura beaucoup de
frappes à longue distance avec des jeux
VT puissants et je pense où il y aura
mais je dis pas parce que je veux pas
qu'il y ait plus d'artillerie ou plus de
chars parce qu'il nous faut plus
d'artillerie plus de chars il y aura
sans doute une première phase avec une
grande bataille aérienne et navale avec
en tout cas beaucoup de tirs de missiles
longues distances avant avant une
opération terrestre et l'offensive
terrestre mais après évidemment tout est
possible il y a différentes guerres de
haute intensité possible
monsieur le Président je suis désolé
j'espère que j'ai répondu à peu près
toutes les questions
je crois que c'est le cas mon général et
nous vous remercions pour cette
intervention extrêmement précise et très
très intéressant je crois que c'est une
très bonne contribution aussi au travail
de rétech qui est engagé par la
commission merci à vous
juste pour vous dire en général que
j'espère en tout cas que les travaux du
Sénat seront davantage et entendus ou lu
parce que si on a réussi à aboutir à
l'armement des drones en 2017 on en a
pas moins expliqué depuis 2017 que
l'usage des drones allait devenir un
atout considérable et qu'on a
réactualisé le rapport en 2021 en
expliquant qu'il fallait davantage aller
vers du drone consommable à faible coût
et malheureusement malgré ce qu'on écrit
tous ici depuis un certain temps on est
peu écouté donc je voulais pas les
industriels pour faire ça monsieur le
sénateur il arrive je connais des
industriels qui ont décidé de se cesser
bien
en général je vous remercie nous allons
continuer les travaux de notre
commission justement de rapporteur de la
mission onute se préparer et en
attendant je voudrais mes chers
collègues vous demandez de procéder à la
désignation de deux rapporteurs sur des
conventions qui seront examinées le 8
février prochain par la commission
premier point pour l'accord avec la
Principauté d'Andorre